allez vas-y que pousseur encore veut
encore là où la gauche n'a pas tenté
attention n'attrape rien n'arrive à les
prêts à la hâte et ge plus touche
perçoit rien je crois que c'est bien
mais bien là ça me semble parfait ni moi
tu crois qu'il va arriver à temps
j'espère bien bonjour vous savez nous
attendant pierre barbizet ne vois là
bonjour pierre on vous attendait avec
impatience vous savez c'est casimir il a
perdu la cassette du catalogue en dehors
de sabrina leur ont essayé tous les deux
devront enregistrer un autre monde
aussi connais pas tellement on vous
attendait avec impatience pour nous
aider c'est oui bon tu vas chercher son
voile à florence il doit françois nous
allons faire un petit tour de savoir on
va faire ça en parlant de chronologique
oui si vous voulez points on pense ou de
la musique commence pas à bac mais enfin
une ceinture marron classique a pris
vraiment une forme définitive avec bach
d'importance jean sébastien bach les
enfants vous avez dit c'est quand même
puis après bye déjà eu beaucoup de
grands musées avec mozart mais on en a
pas et autour de mozart vous rappeler
que les variations maman on a fait près
le manitoba oui alors bétonnant pour
être un petit peu de beto c'est un
casimir est important oui chef il ya eu
chopin il ya eu sumann un peu plus près
de nous bien la liste oui et puis puis a
eu d'abus si on en a vu l'autre jour
aussi il y à bartok initiale puis laqué
beaucoup trop de merveilleux alors
battez vous avez vous joué un petit peu
du concerto italien
c'est très beau c'est comme même pas
grand orient toi qu'est-ce qui est pas
le baptise la peau dure et gorillaz
m'excuse mais si tu acceptes c'est quand
même pas mal
[Musique]
e
pour
[Musique]
où
ces problèmes c'est pas mal une grande
soirée
alors c'est très très religieux c'est
très méditatif vous plaît ça non pas
trop quand même
tu verras ajouté moi ça c'est dommage
c'est déjà fini
le temps passe vite avec pierre barbizet
mais ne vous inquiétez pas il reviendra